i traveled here to the uk to testify
as a witness to assist the court
after obtaining a restraining order in
2016
and finalizing my divorce
i just wanted to move on with my life
i did not file this lawsuit
and despite its significance
i would have preferred not to be here in
court
[Music]
it has been incredibly painful to relive
the breakup of my relationship
to have my motives my truth questioned
and the most traumatic and intimate
details of my life with johnny
shared in court and broadcast
to the entire world
i stand by my testimony
and i now place my faith in british
justice
although i did not bring up this lawsuit
i am aware of the precious resources
being consumed by his litigation
[Music]
and i will be glad to see those re
resources redirected
to more important legal matters delayed
by the kovid 19 pandemic
i appreciate the dedication the hard
work
and support of the defense legal team
as well as my u.s and uk lawyers
i also wish to extend my thanks to the
very diligent
and kind court staff and the police
who have been so sensitive in ensuring
my safety my protection
so that i could testify in safety
and finally my heartfelt thanks
for all of the tremendous and
overwhelming outpouring of support that
i have received and the many messages
from all over the world
you have given me so much strength
and i send it back to you
thank you